so Turkey has now struck Kurdish targets
in northeastern Syria according to a new
report now when we say as I just
discussed with you we all want to be out
of Syria but if we just bail Turkey will
attack the Kurds it's not a hypothetical
political consideration it's not some
random way to try to criticize what
Donald Trump does it's real and in fact
it happened within hours of the United
States
pulling troops from northern Syria in
conjunction with Donald Trump's
announcement right after even some
Republicans said wait wait wait a second
what about the Kurds Turkey has already
struck targets belonging to Kurdish
opposition groups in the northeast of
Syria right now the north of Syria is
controlled by the Kurdish SDF that's
Syrian democratic forces they are our
allies they've been fighting Isis this
is why this is what better said a lot of
Trumpets don't get who just continued to
see all of this as team sports the
actions of Trump have real-world
consequences and you have these sort of
reflexive defenses of anything that
Donald Trump does no matter what it is
but then you see that the impact is real
Trump pulls troops turkey bombs the
Kurds now Trump said we have the tweet
that he would obliterate Turkey's
economy if they do the wrong thing to
the Kurds we looked at the tweet last
segment let's look at it one more time
as I have strongly stated before Trump
tweeted yesterday and just to reiterate
if Turkey does anything that I in my
great and unmatched wisdom considered to
be off-limits I will totally destroy and
obliterate the capital II economy of
Turkey I've done before we still don't
know what that I've done before means
none of this is surprising we've known
for a long time that Turkey and air
Dewan wanted to attack the Kurds now
there is a very obvious and cynical
analysis to be made I will present it to
you there are Trump Towers in Turkey her
Dewan knows something about the cash og
killing that would be bad for
to have go public given that Trump did
nothing with regard to Saudi Arabia
after we found out about Saudi Arabia's
role responsibilities in that killing
both Putin and erawan want Syria's
regime to stand so this becomes a really
clever geopolitical proxy to repress the
Kurds a more egalitarian society in
support of dictator Bashar al-assad and
Trump is the perfect Patsy
to fold under the most minor pressure
this that's one analysis okay and that
accounts for like 95 percent of what we
know and what we're seeing it would
explain 95 percent of the factors now
let me address another issue there are
some leftists who are saying Trump
derangement syndrome is making leftists
defend troops in Syria
Trump has so rattled the left that he is
making the left be in favor of forever
wars just to oppose Donald Trump when
did the left become war mongers is
another way that it's being said stop
back up a second okay
this is a very specific situation that
we are analyzing here Noam Chomsky no
hero of American imperialism and
military expansion has said it makes
sense for the u.s. to maintain a
presence in Syria right now to deter
attacks against the Kurds to pretend
that recognizing the folly of this
decision by Donald Trump is a
militaristic decision of expanding
forever Wars is extraordinarily myopic
and it's also dangerous to the Kurds to
start pushing lines like that
geopolitics is complicated much more
complicated than troops anywhere are bad
get them all out any time no matter what
no matter why please apply a little more
thought to what is going on here because
it is I mean listen we expect the right
to be making completely ridiculous
fact-free analyses of what we are seeing
take place on the foreign policy stage
whether they reflectively reflexively
defend any
decision that Trump makes whether they
reflexively favor and support anything
that involves putting the military in
different places we expect this from
them the the really disgusting thing
that I don't want to see is the left
start starting to eat itself over
analyses that make no sense this is not
about opposing Trump and therefore
supporting forever Wars or endless
indefinite military engagements it's
just not this is about understanding
what even people like Noam Chomsky are
saying and recognizing that they're with
Trump as always maybe other factors of
financial factors leverage factors etc
that are not being publicized that could
very much inform why we're seeing what
we're seeing
we'll be tracking the fallout make sure
that you're following the david pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
and while you're there follow me at
david pakman